deux mille cinq cents adolescents de
chambéry et des environs attendaient
avec impatience l'ouverture de la
nouvelle maison des jeunes de la culture
de la ville les activités éparpillés un
peu partout vont désormais être
centralisées elles n'en seront que plus
de dynamisme
samedi monsieur pierre dumas secrétaire
d'état au tourisme et maire de la cité a
inauguré les locaux misano en présence
de monsieur montreuil des parlementaires
du département et de nombreuses
personnalités
il a coupé le ruban symbolique et le
cortège officiel a découvert des
installations modernes les pratiques des
cours de peinture ont déjà été
organisées sous la responsabilité de
monsieur deux tiers sans mais d'autres
sections ont vu le jour et notamment
celle de musique de chant le jazz club a
évidemment une place de choix comme le
score en a eu et la gymnastique et ne
manquera pas d'adeptes tout le monde
sans les risques